i haven't made a seeing science video in
a while but it's when i got tagged in
this tick tock video a bunch of times by
bonky bird
[Music]
i just felt compelled to use the highly
creative percussion that bunky bird
makes here in order to create a
soundtrack and to collaborate correctly
with this bird i'm gonna have to work
with animal music making specialists no
other than my good friend the kifnus who
makes both hilarious and dope beats with
animals like
[Music]
this video is sponsored by my good
friends at epidemic silent and music
which i'll tell you more about at the
end of this video
how's it bro
how's it going welcome to jovick shut
dude
[Music]
so like i'll just drop the video into
ableton get an idea of like
the bpm
around 140
[Music]
i can also be making other sounds
we've got a little bird pond there
like splash around i don't know quite an
interesting sound
i feel bad to steal food from the birds
could turn this into shaker i guess yeah
we can do something with this
[Music]
today's another day to do the same thing
flying
okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
great that was it i felt good felt good
as i told you before this video was
brought to you by epidemic sound which
is my go-to sound and music library
epidemic sound makes your job as a
creator or professional as smooth as it
can be no matter if you're editing a
commercial or an instagram reel their
sole purpose is to empower creativity
and at the same time make life a little
bit easier for you by signing up to
epidemic sound you get access to 35 000
tracks 90 000 sound effects in a wide
variety of genres and moods with curated
playlists for occasions and themes it's
easy to find what you're looking for and
you can enjoy fresh new music added
every week you can now get personalized
recommendations of tracks based on your
recent downloads or based on what music
you've used on your channel previously
and the more you use the product the
more they get to know what you like
thank you so much for watching this week
seeing science video and other than that
don't forget you're awesome brew and oh
wait um comment like and subscribe for
the algorithm to
yeah don't forget you're awesome bruh
and i'll see you next week
[Music]